good morning sir morning how are you
good stoic are you tired second I turned
me too I thought the morning voice yeah
me too
it's just called spaceship no it doesn't
have like a fancy name ultimate
spaceship of time of time this area
because I thought about it this area
looks like a little spaceship have you
been through a lot of Wars galactic wars
now no no okay this baby needs gas I
need gas gotcha
it is a weekday and yeah take Isaac at
school this is literally the morning
routine since Isaac goes to an
after-school program always like Isaac
basically two lunches so that way you
can have a lunch for school during lunch
and then he has another sandwich and
drink Oh time to go time for school
whoo where are you are you at the top
whoa oh what's the password the password
is Isaac's the coolest baddest kid in
the world
oh all right what time is it
it is 7:40 all right so it's my turn to
take I see to school mommy still
sleeping morning
so woman here will be back all right
we're going to schools and I'm gonna put
on my seatbelt so we're on our way you
know
Oh
[Music]
all right goodbye goodbye have fun oh
yeah the Albert Einstein all right some
more narrow trainings done at the office
now and trying to get some writing all
right so this is dope
I'm actually the first one here for the
meeting and I'm usually always the last
one here I'm always late and I'm
actually always kind of pushing the
meetings back by like 15 to 30 minutes
every single day I'm actually early for
once
but yeah here's the n95 right here
trying to figure out this thing's a
puzzle piece
but we're progressing
[Music]
so another writing day is done and sorry
I can't show you too much of it just
because it's top-secret stuff but I
can't wait to show you guys once the
movies finish which is still a long ways
away so sorry you're just gonna have to
wait I don't know I think the difference
between making a movie as a youtuber
especially as a vlogger is that you want
to incorporate everything that's
happening in your life in your vlogs to
us we announce a lot of things that are
happening in real time how that's
different from like actual filmmakers
that work in the industry is that they
keep everything under wraps everything's
under wraps a movie idea could have been
born ten years prior to the movie coming
out and of course we're not gonna
announce it they only announced movies
being made when they're ready to shoot
usually you know sometimes they'll have
announcement oh they're gonna start
writing this thing but if cast this
actor but it's usually like big moves
where like that project is well underway
whereas for us our project was never it
well underway when we announced it and I
think for us we're trying really hard
not to make a YouTube movie and there's
a lot of youtubers that have made movies
and I can't say that they suck but
they're not comparable to what you would
say is a real movie there's a
discrepancy in terms of the quality of
work so with that said we're putting a
lot of effort into this process right
now to make sure it's not going to fall
into the category of a YouTube film
hopefully not I mean we say all these
things but we're you know it might come
back and bite us in the butt in our
movie ends up being like crap I think we
had to keep telling ourselves that we're
not making a crappy movie we were making
a good movie and we had to aim higher
than what we're probably capable of if
you aim high and you fall short you'll
still probably fail in a better place
than if you weren't aiming as high so I
think that's kind of like the philosophy
we're going into this so hopefully it
pays off I don't know it's find out what
Tiff's doing she's preparing for JK news
I know that much just because it's
Wednesday Thursday's are JK news days so
she's probably busy studying news
articles right now look who's home
muy bien can we carry this conversation
in Spanish for longer you say something
is I don't know anything else Gothel
there we go yeah dude said yes what's
got to say I don't know that 14 or how
nice it got Thor says yeah his big boy
bubbler can room captain Senor Cola
translation I always try to teach you
Spanish but you never listen no actually
the opposite I said it's my fault
because I never teach you Spanish
anymore there's a lot of fans that
comment and they say it's a shame that
isay doesn't know Spanish what do you
think about that such a genuine and
honest answer like I'm sorry man no I
honestly I'm the one that gets the most
playing which I should I deserve it I'm
the mother he should know
I personally blame kz y widely Isaac and
I we used to speak Spanish every single
day about like 70% of the whole day's
conversation would be in Spanish oh but
then since being with you you don't
understand Spanish so we just speak
English all the time so I just stopped
using my Spanish I only use my Spanish
now and over on the New Mexico so and
then there's people saying well why
don't you just teach Casey Spanish like
it's so easy to pick up the language
like that not only that but the reason
why I refuse is because I'm like you
don't want to teach me Cantonese so why
do I have to teach you Spanish cuz
Cantonese is a dying language doesn't
matter it's whole country of China says
we're getting rid of all the other
dialects or they're not teaching yet it
doesn't matter to me Mandarin which is
the power language of China my argument
is don't you want your kids to know your
native language yeah I guess so I don't
know maybe I'm not as prideful that's
not true though can I'm pretty proud of
like my heritage and stuff I just I
don't know I don't see it there's no
like I mean you aren't Chinese
perhaps I grew up pretty white but yeah
that's kind of like the problems of
being the interracial relationship is
that your original heritage gets very
watered down once you get cuz and now
you have to kind of compromise the
lifestyle a bit you get to learn a lot
about other peoples you know cultures
and you get to blend it which is
beautiful but at the same time by
blending it you you end up watering it
down so it's uh it's a catch-22 and then
it was funny to sing some comments on
our honeymoon video when I was talking
about how I felt more connected to Spain
than Mexico we were flipping out you
will first toy agree what it's like I
actually am genetically more connected
to Spain than I am Mexico so 23andme
Casey and I we both did 23andme a while
ago it Riku lit a do one for Isaac
because yeah makes like crazy he's his
dad is Peruvian what you say is a high
percentage of Asian blood yeah and his
dad thinks that he has an Asian ancestor
too so I think Isaac has like part Asian
of genes would it be cool if we were
actually related somehow cool look at
this 53.4% your opinion it's like 19%
19.5% Iberian 1.2 which is the which is
the area where Spain and Portugal really
are okay Portugal is Iberian
I think it's called Peninsula or
something so I am genetically more
connected to Spain guys don't get all
flipped out on me just because I said I
didn't feel that connected to Mexico
it's me we got doing for you you want to
do what yep
all you have to do is spit in - oh my
god this sounds like a perfect
opportunity to do a brand deal with them
but 23andme but it's not a brand deal
definitely not a brand deal but but yes
all you do is spit into a tube after not
have eaten food and you can't have brush
your teeth you can't have kissed anyone
you can't you kissing anyone you know
okay good alright I won't bother you you
know
- do I have a lot of work Wednesday
nights is cramming day is taking news
nights over Wednesday night shout out I
am
alright so homework is done and we're
gonna play it a little bit in the
clubhouse it's grown-up proof yep I take
very seriously sometimes look who came
to visit us in that Clubhouse that's the
play no - no player do you he doesn't
know if he's still deciding Wednesday
nights are my least favorite nights cuz
she's always working yeah Jackie News
consumes my Wednesday night it's cool I
get to spend a whole day with my friends
and talk about what's happening in the
world so it's pretty cool it's just
there's a lot of prep that goes into it
luckily I have Jess and Pat that helps
me prepare so it's not all on my
shoulders which is a good thing but it's
still a lot it's a lot to do whatever
they do I have to finalize like for
example the titles or the headlines or
photos and video they'll help me with
some notes and I have to go over it and
figure out how I'm going to report it
whatever studying that goes into it you
don't have to look through a lot of
different articles and a lot of
different sources to get the story
cross-referencing yeah but that's super
time-consuming so sometimes like you
know I'll do my best but obviously I'm
not gonna know everything about
everything and then a lot of the times
which really sucks is when I'll report a
story that just happened
and so I have very limited information
but then by the time the video comes out
the rest of the information comes out so
then it looks like I didn't do all the
research I should have done so then I
get a lot of complaints from people
saying like
if you need to study or check your
sources or blah blah blah and I'm like
I'm trying guys like I can only do so
much you know yeah being put in this
position is it can get stressful yeah I
try to do my best so that's why I'm
Wednesday nights I'm like so focused and
I'm just trying to like okay I need to
try to know as much as I can about each
story so that's why my Wednesday nights
are gone for news and then you suffer so
I have to go go back in
no more talking sorry they're so funny
that first one was fast you're looking
pretty good oh now you're hey today not
your day today
[Music]